Loaders provide a framework to
perform a synchronous loading of data.
They are registered by ID with a loader
manager, which allows them to live
beyond the life cycle of the activity or
fragment they are associated with.
In addition to loading data, loaders
include mechanisms to monitor the source
of their data, and deliver new
results when the contents change.
Up till now, we've used AsyncTask
to load data from the internet and
Sunshine.
We typically create our AsyncTask in
the onCreate method of our activity.
It starts a thread which
begins a background task.
If we rotate the device, or
do something else that requires
the activity to be restarted,
we'll create another AsyncTask
to do the background operation.
We'll create extra network usage, or
file system usage as both
threads run in parallel.
And, it'll take a longer time for
the user to see the result of the load.
The AsyncTask Loader implements the same
functionality as Async Task, but
because it's a loader,
it's lifecycle is different.
With an Async Task Loader,
once we rotate the device,
the loader manager will make sure
that the old loader is connected to
the Async Task Loader
equivalent of on post execute.
The onLoadFinished function.
The loader thread keeps running in
the loadInBackground function, and
once it finishes the activity gets
notified through onLoadFinished.
CursorLoader is derived
from Async Task Loader but
has an additional optimization.
If the cursor has already
finished loading and
load in background before
the activity restarts,
the CursorLoader recognizes this
during the loader initialization.
And the cursor is immediately delivered
to the UI through onLoadFinished